[Music]
i have a question your cell phone rings
and you don't recognize the number what
do you do
ignore it don't answer it not me i like
life
the other day my cell phone rang 917.
that's a new york number i didn't know
who it was i picked it up anyway i hit
talk i said hello guy in the line goes
hey bruce what's going on
my name's jay not bruce
so i said nothing much man what's going
on with
you and he said i'll tell you what's
going on i just got an email about the
budget it's supposed to be fifteen
thousand now it's ten thousand and i'd
like to know what's up
i got excited in my chest
i grabbed the steering wheel i was like
okay focus your name is bruce there's a
budget it was fifteen thousand now it's
ten thousand no one's happy about it
that's all we know that's all we know
so i just repeated back to him what he
said to me and i go ten thousand is
supposed to be fifteen thousand
he goes yeah i know well i just got an
email and now it's ten i go listen man i
don't tell you i've been on the road all
day you know i haven't even seen it and
he goes did you send this out
give him some attitude to bruce
i didn't like it
i said listen man the budget was fifteen
thousand we had a couple extra
expenditures it went up to sixteen two i
reworked it got it down to fourteen
seven i had three hundred to play with
so i called it 15 and i sent it out
and he goes yeah well now it's 10 man
and i was like oh my god that worked
that worked
phase one complete phase one complete
like now i'm in the door i have a 401k i
was at the christmas party okay
so he goes did larry okay this
i go listen man i took the budget to
larry larry said it looked fine but i
knew it was my ass on the line so i ran
it by jennifer just in case just to
double check jennifer said it looked
good i sent it out he goes yeah well now
it's ten man
and i realized this guy has no idea
what's going on over there
he hasn't talked to larry i know he
hasn't talked to bruce he doesn't even
recognize my voice
i know i didn't talk to jennifer i just
made her up
so he goes listen man what are we gonna
do about this and i go listen i'm on the
road right now i haven't even seen the
email why don't you give larry call
check in with him see what he says call
me back
just praying he will because that return
phone call was going to be amazing
and he goes you know what why don't wait
till you get home you check the email
you call larry you call me back and i go
nah nah bro larry knows way more about
this than i do give him a call call me
back he goes okay hangs up the phone
to which i explode with euphoria
because there's a small business in new
york that is crumbling to the
ground over five grand and nobody can
find jennifer
they're looking they're looking
i get home i'm so excited i take out my
cell phone i'm like you know what i'm
gonna save that guy's number give him a
call in a couple days touch base you
know what i mean check it
see where we're at you know
so i save it in my phone under random
guy that's what he is he's a random guy
four or five days pass i forget about it
laying on my couch watching the ball
game phone rings in the dining room
table i get up watching the game grab
the phone watching the game look down
random guy
but it's been a couple days you know
what i mean so i'm like random guy who's
random guy like who would even have
random guy as their name that comes up
and then i was like
random guy
like now i'm panicked you know what i
mean people's lives have been affected
it's only five grand but i don't know
how big that company is
but i'm addicted to it you know what i
mean i started this thing i need to see
it through
so i put my earbuds in just get a little
distance you know i just see a little
space
and i hit talk
same guy goes hey larry what's going on
yeah now he's calling me larry he knows
something's up but i'm not about to back
down i go nothing much man what's going
on with you
and he goes well i got us on conference
call with janelle and marie
and i was like okay here we go here we
go
this is why we play the game you guys
this is why we play the game
so i go welcome to the call ladies as if
to say welcome to the show you know what
i mean here we go
marie takes the lead she goes hey larry
what time is it where you are i live in
l.a they're in new york it's 5 30. so i
go 8 30 it's 8 30. she was really what's
the weather like and i was like oh
weather's nice weather's nice
she goes you know this doesn't sound
like larry and i go oh yeah who's it
sound like and a random guy chirps him
from the back and he goes sounds like
bruce sounds like bruce
like he's gonna blow this case wide open
and i go listen guys this isn't larry
and it isn't bruce
and marie goes who is this
i said i'm just some guy who had nothing
better to do than to mess with you guys
and marie got pissed she was not happy
she was you understand we're trying to
run a business over here i was like yeah
well i got that from the budget i just
figured it was a business
and she goes what do you think this is
some kind of joke and i was like a
little bit thought it's pretty funny
that's pretty funny and she goes let me
ask you something and i go no you let me
ask you something
and she goes what and i go
where are we at with the budget
[Applause]
jay larson